[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICIA SCANLAN: Thank you.
Thanks for the
invitation to come here.
So I'll just talk to you
about the company SoapBox Labs
to start with.
We do children's speech
recognition technologies.
So 2017 and 2018 were, like,
huge years for voice assistance
across the world.
It started, I think it was
in 2015 when Amazon first
released the Alexa
into the US market,
and it's taken a long time to
get to the side of the ocean.
And since then we've
seen newcomers come on.
But more recent,
we know that Google
came on the heels of
Alexa, Apple this year--
Facebook are talking about a
device by the end of this year.
They postponed it, but still
looks like it's coming out.
And what's changed over
the last couple of years
is people are beginning to
see the utility of voice
assistance.
A couple of years ago, speech
recognition technologies
were probably working
in the 80% accuracy.
So that meant they were still
quite frustrating to work with.
So people began--
just kind of doubted
it would every really take off.
But myself, I've been working
in this area for over 20 years,
and it was kind of a case
of once deep learning,
vast volumes of data
and GPU's and all that
came together, we could
see the scale of it,
and we could see the utility.
I spent some time working
on IBM a long time ago--
IBM Research.
And back in 2004,
we actually saw
a demo of the voice assistant.
The idea was somebody would
be driving in their car,
and they would want
to go to a restaurant,
and the car would ask them--
the assistant would ask
about what kind of restaurant
did you want to go
to, and give them
real time feedback on traffic,
and direct them to where to go.
And it was 2003, I think, 2004.
So when I was there, and I was a
research assistant at the time,
I said that was imminent.
This is what they were
going to put in cars.
And our understanding
was a year or two,
and it's actually
taken this long
to get real voice
assistance of real utility.
And what's happened
there is accuracy.
It's actually less frustrating.
So if you tried it
a few years ago,
it was extremely frustrating.
It got it wrong too often.
That's all.
It wasn't that it was getting
it wrong all the time,
but just too often.
That was a frustrating
experience.
And that's what's
changed in recent years.
But it's not just the
voice assistance, right.
There's any number
of these companies
that are seriously doing speech
recognition technologies.
So I think Tech
Crunch late 2016 said
there was like 29
companies in the US
alone doing speech recognition.
So that's not counting
Asia; it's not
counting European companies,
and it's not counting
what's happened in 2018, right.
That's a year and a half ago.
But all these companies are
doing spectacular things,
so you're seeing
voice assistance.
You know, when we had
them first, it was Siri,
and it OK, Google, and it
was on your personal device.
But they've taken a leap
from the personal device
into the home, and that's really
interesting from my perspective
what's happened there.
You know it's something we all
have to pay close attention to,
because it's just the
tip of the iceberg.
I mean, people think wow, look
at this amazing technology
and what it's going do
for them, but to my mind,
this is just the start.
It will be, even from
our own experiences
of the last couple of years--
it will be on your
fridge, your TV, your car.
It could be in a
vending machine.
It's not just that
it's a voice assistant.
It's actually going to be the
stage that speech technology--
voice technology is going
to replace keyboards, touch,
swipe, gesture, all these
things, because it's
the natural interface.
It's how humans communicate.
So it only makes sense that
if technology can do it
to that stage, why are we all
still typing, and clicking,
and you know, we have to do that
because the technology wasn't
there to begin with.
But what happens with
that is when we actually
start replacing interface,
and voice becomes the norm,
you have to recognize the fact
that you've put it in the home,
and children will use it.
I mean, that's just a given.
It's not about what
you want or whatever.
If you volunteer
to take something
and put it into the home,
it will engage children,
because, number one, it's fun.
What child isn't going to
try it the moment you do it.
They're going to do it
immediately after you.
But it's also easier for them
than clicking and typing,
because a lot of times
they're even pre-literate
or they struggle with dexterity.
It's actually a great
interface for children as well,
and it's already there.
So the question is,
how do we handle it?
What's the utility?
So in every place that you
could see an adult using
speech technology other
than dictating your business
documents, you're going to see
that children will use it, too,
especially when you take it
outside the office environment,
and you're going to see
that they're using it.
Other application areas we
see for it in particular is--
and what we started
with, actually,
SoapBox Labs originally, our
mission statement back in 2013
was more around education.
So if you think about how
a child learns to read,
the most effective way
a child learns to read
is one-to-one,
oral-guided reading.
So that means a helpful adult
working alongside a child.
And if you think, do you ever
watch a parent or a teacher
teaching a child to read,
they listen, they correct,
they prompt, they
encourage, and they assess.
And it's that
one-to-one, actually--
it's more than 10 minutes a day,
but between 10 and 20 minutes
a day is recommended
for a child to get to--
to accelerate the reading
to a decent level.
But in the world
today, literacy levels
have stagnated over
the last 10 years.
In the US, 60% of
kids at age eight
are not reading at
a proficient level.
And a child that doesn't read
at a proficient level of age
eight, it's a key indicator
of their future success;
it's quite a key
moment, because it's
when most kids stop
learning to read,
and they start reading to learn.
So if you are
struggling before that,
it's going to get
harder and harder
to catch up with your peers.
So one of the ways we've been
looking at this over the years
is that if you know the one
way to increase the reading is
one-to-one engagement,
you're not suddenly
going to find funding to stick
more teachers into homes,
or suddenly free up parents'
time, or get private tutors.
But what you can do is provide
a scalable, cost-effective
solution in speech
technology that can actually
act as a helpful adult,
listening as the child reads,
the cat sat on the mat,
and correcting, prompting,
and assessing, and do
that personalized learning
journey for them.
And the same goes for
English language learning,
or other language learning,
depending on where your from.
The same thing-- it's
that guided or really
personalized learning,
personalized education
is a huge area in
the world today.
But actually nobody has a
solution really for reading.
And they can do it for maths,
and science, and geography,
but they can't do
it for reading.
They can't do it from
language learning.
And the statistics
about poor reading
is actually masking a
big, much worse problem
for disadvantaged children
and immigrant children,
because those kids are actually
two years behind their peers
in PISA studies.
So they're the kids that
probably would benefit the most
from these type of technologies
that are cost-effective,
that are scalable.
And all they required is
a cheap Android device,
and means to one
of those devices.
So that's one of the
areas we're focused on.
Another area that we've had a
huge amount of inbound interest
in social robots, it's
called, or robotics
for fun, entertainment, get
them to move around, but also
social robots to
engage to learn--
engage them in an educational
way, or a lot of times,
kids with learning
difficulties as well.
But again, voice
technology to have
that meaningful interaction
is really important.
The more fun stuff like in VR,
which also can be educational,
but it also can be just
pure entertainment,
and then just pure
gaming as well.
Anywhere you see voice
technology for adults
could then--
the solutions for children
as well make sense.
So I'm just going to show
you a quick video here,
and this is one
of the reasons why
our focus in the last five years
have been somewhat different.
I'll just play this for you, and
you'll understand what I mean.
So this is when you stick a
voice assistant into the home,
and what can go wrong.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Alexa, play "Digger, Digger."
- I can't find the
song, "T Good Ticker."
- Alexa--
- Alexa, play [INAUDIBLE]
- Let him do it.
- Alexa, play "Digger, Digger."
Alexa, play "Digger, Digger."
Bobby, can you tell it to
play "Wheels on the Bus"?
- You want to hear
a station for porn
detective, porno ringtone,
hot chick amateur girl quality
sex--
- No no no.
- No.
- Pussy anal dildo ringtone.
- Alexa, stop.
[END PLAYBACK]
PATRICIA SCANLAN: So it's
a funny, cute video, right,
but it actually indicates
kind of more serious problems
they have when you put
a device into the home.
Where is the filter?
You know, you can say it's
not designed for kids;
it's not marketed to kids; I
didn't put it there for kids.
But kids are going to use it,
and we have to face up to that,
right.
So some of the focus of our
company over the last five
years has been accuracy
for children's voices,
systems environments that are
fit for kids, and data privacy.
So accuracy, why is
speech technology
difficult for children?
Most systems have been built
with adult data, modeling adult
behaviors, physical
and otherwise.
But children are physically
different from adults,
particularly in the vocal tract.
They're thinner and shorter.
So where men's voices
might be lower,
women's are
overlapping but higher,
and then let's says
a tween, teenager,
is kind of overlapping women.
And as they get younger,
the physical differences
get further and further
away from an adult,
and that happens around age 12.
And the younger you get,
the more different it is.
And that actually
just physically
causes confusion about what
actually has been said.
The behaviors, on
the other hand,
are just wildly different.
Kids are wildly unpredictable.
They stutter, they repeat, they
shout, they whisper, they sing.
Like, you know, they punctuate
their words an awful lot more
than their more fluent older
siblings, and other children,
and adults.
And that actually is a real
problem for endpoint detection,
if anybody's ever
worked on that,
because they don't just
behave the same way.
And what you end up
doing is seeing that
a system that has been
designed for adults,
or using adult data, or
modeling adult behavior,
it's extremely
frustrating for a child,
and the younger the child,
the more frustrating it is.
It has a negative effect
on brand in some ways,
because people associate
that technology.
A lot of people don't
process the fact
that it's just different voices.
They just think the product
isn't working very well.
And you know, I had
a pain in my head
from my younger son
asking me, can you
ask Alexa, when
we got her first.
So what we've done is spend the
last five years concentrating
on child-specific models.
So what we did was look at
data from children as young
as four--
but the data was conversational,
prompted, read, spontaneous--
and built models that were very
specific to young children.
We spent time studying
how children converse,
how children speak
to technology,
the variance in that, and
how do you cope with that,
and how do you build a
system specifically designed
for children.
We collected data in
real world environments.
So that mean, you
know, where children
are in their homes
and their schools.
And so you can
actually understand
that children don't
use technology
in a quiet lab-like environment.
And if you build your
speech technology
on data that's been collected in
a lab-like, quiet environment,
it will only ever work
in those environments.
So to move away from that,
you have to be able to--
and get away from headset mics,
and get away from all that,
and then let children just
be natural with how they want
to interact with technology.
And then it's more up to
us to change our technology
than the child to
change their behaviors,
because you won't
find a five year old
that's going to modify
their behavior as
much as an adult will.
And that's how we've
been getting away
with a lot with voice
technology and assistance,
that we know that
adults sometimes
modify their behaviors
to get a response.
Children are less
likely to do so.
So another issue is, is the
system fit for children,
and are they appropriate?
So two examples I
can give you of this
is that Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
the press secretary for Donald
Trump, recently tweeted that
her three year old ordered
a Batman on Amazon Alexa,
because she shouted Batman
at the device three times,
and suddenly it got ordered.
So I call that
somewhat into question
that the UI works like
that, but it kind of
did flag up an issue.
If a child uses a device that
has access to purchasing power,
why is that child able to do it?
That's not appropriate behavior
for a child interacting
with a device in the home.
Similarly, my daughter
was-- she's eight now--
she was using my phone, and
you know, I had it locked,
but she got onto the Siri
thing, and she was just
sitting with me and using
Siri to ask questions.
Siri misunderstood, and
thought she said, bitch.
She didn't, but my
daughter was shocked,
and showed me the phone with
the word printed to the screen.
And Siri replied
with an, oh, there's
no need for that, which
is very amusing and nice,
but why didn't it recognize
that was a child voice,
and not print that to screen?
So I think when you consider
the fact of the first video
with the child
potentially accessing
inappropriate material,
inappropriate lyrics, songs,
purchasing power,
inappropriate words,
potentially accessing
your contact list
and doing video
calling or whatever--
what needs to happen is,
and what we've been working
with clients to
do, is to recognize
at the point of the
voice interaction--
whether it's a child or
whether it's an adult--
and act appropriately.
Route the child to a different,
child-safe environment,
and not to the wide
web where they can do
an open search and such things.
And that's important when we
put these devices in the homes,
and in the cars, and
in all the places
that children will access them.
So data privacy-- the really
thorny issue of data privacy.
This is obviously such a hot
topic in the last few weeks.
But interestingly, the US are
way ahead of Europe on this.
Going back to 2012,
the US COPPA laws
explicitly stated that voice
was personally identifiable
information, much like
video and images were,
and therefore you needed
to have explicit permission
from the parents
to collect data.
And explicit is
very explicit; it's
like using their credit
card to make a purchase,
or having the parent put
in their email address,
email sent to the parent, the
parents had to click consent,
and then you have to
remind them that they
consented, and written
in language that they
can understand.
It was very explicit--
and warranted, right?
But with the advent of these
voice assistants in the home,
the FTC relaxed the
rules only very recently,
and said, OK, we understand that
these devices are in the home,
so therefore if it
replaces the voice,
replaces what would
have been typed,
it's OK to use it for
only that purpose,
and as long as it
deleted immediately.
So it's great.
So that meant, in most
people's minds, OK,
we're good to use
it in the home.
But what it was not
considering was--
a couple of issues is what
happens on the back end.
You collect data from
a child; is the data
deleted immediately, which
meant you need a gate for child
or not-child data.
Is the data deleted immediately?
Is there data
extracted for that?
Is the data extracted
used for other purposes?
What's that data used for?
So while we can
somewhat say that we're
addressing some of
these issues, it
has been very unclear to
date exactly what data
has been collected, exactly
when the data is being deleted,
and what's the data used for.
And that is, because
it's an exploding area,
and the area is
growing so quickly,
it's often hard for
the laws and the FTC
to really struggle with this,
and kind of came up very short
in it about what to do.
What happens if you've given
permission to your child
to use the device, and
the data they collected,
but the child's friend
visits the house.
What happens to that data?
Is that being addressed?
What if you just take the device
out of the box and put it here?
You know, is everybody
being sure that the data is
being deleted immediately?
And that's really
a thorny issue.
So the FTC relaxed the rule.
So a lot of people are
now in gray water, going,
they think we're OK--
we, the public who have
put that device in the home
are unsure when the data
is being deleted exactly.
The EU and the GDPR--
the much-feared
GDPR, in May 2018,
have not relaxed the rule.
That means that data is
not allowed to be collected
without explicit permission.
So you take a device,
you pull it out,
you put it in your home,
and you plug it in.
A child uses it.
Where is the responsibility?
Is everybody
immediately reacting,
recognizing that a child
has spoken versus an adult,
and reacting appropriately?
So the problem here is that
because the FTC kind of took
a bit of a backstep and a blind
eye for for a couple of years,
and then it got
sorted out, the idea
that the EU would do the same
is a little bit less clear.
One reason I would say
that is because last year,
the Cayla doll was recalled
from the market in Germany.
And not just was it
recalled, what came out
was that parents should destroy
this doll because the doll is
listening to your
children at all times,
and sending the voice
data to a company that
has links to the US military.
And that company was
Nuance, which you know,
it's a very reputable
voice technology
company, around for
a long time, and they
have done DARPA projects.
So technically it was correct,
but the reaction from Germany
was so polar opposite to
what we've seen already
in the FTC and the
US that I think
it should give us all pause
to say, how are we doing this?
Are we doing it appropriately?
And I don't think that they're
going to see a blind eye.
So in that case,
somewhat we have
to re-envision how people
are using these technologies.
A part of what we do is
we have advised companies,
and we have solutions to bid
to help companies better comply
with global data
privacy regulations.
So this is just some
of the company--
I mean, we can chat more
about it in a little while,
but this is just on what's
happened with the company.
We started back in 2013.
In 2018 we've raised a
couple rounds of funding
privately and from
the EU as well.
And we've got some great
coverage from "Tech Crunch,"
and "Wired," and "The Next Web,"
and in recent months as well.
So we were 10 at
the end of the year;
we're 13 as of from
this month, and then
we're scaling quite
rapidly this year.
So I can leave it there,
and thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So thank you,
Patricia, and thank you
for that overview.
You talked a lot
about your company,
so I want to take a
few minutes to talk
about you and your
journey, and sort of share
how you've gotten to where
you've gotten to here.
Phenomenal to hear the story--
2013, pure tech, built in
Ireland, scaling company.
So well done on that.
But maybe give us a little
bit of your background,
I mean, the journey
to date, right up
to the start of SoapBox Labs.
PATRICIA SCANLAN: Yeah, sure.
So I qualified as a software
engineer back in '97.
It's been a while ago.
And I spent a couple of years
working as a software engineer,
and worked a bit on
signal processing.
And then about 2000,
I went back to college
to do a PhD in speech
recognition technology, which
was--
it wasn't that it was new.
We've been doing speech tech
since the '70s properly.
But it was so different
to how we do it now,
and the volumes we do it
with, and the approaches were
so different, and the
ambition was different.
I started in UCD,
but I spent time
in New York in
Columbia University,
but then also in IBM Research
in the Yorktown Heights research
facility.
And then when I
finished my PhD, I
started in Bell Labs, which
is now Nokia Bell Labs,
and I spent seven years there
working on research, but then
more and more, as time went on,
in just the commercialization
of research innovations,
and trying to--
I was always kind of pushing
for new technologies,
or new research we should
do, and new products
we could bring to market--
as I was saying,
in some ways kind
of pitching ideas and
raising value propositions,
and trying to get resources
and funding to fund projects
within the organization.
But by 2013 I'd identified the
fairly significant gap which
was children's
speech recognition
that I felt like I needed
to invest time in, and try
and figure out what
the problem was,
and it was something I needed to
do myself, so I quit Bell Labs
and founded SoapBox
Labs in 2013.
SPEAKER 1: And was that
an aha moment, or was
it one of these kind of you
build up to see the problem,
and identified the gap?
How exactly did you come
across this specific problem?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: It was all
my experience up to that point
led me to the aha
moment, if you want.
I was working with my daughter
who was three at the time--
she's now eight--
downloading apps
and web services,
and kind of looking at--
I think I was trying phonics,
and reading apps and stuff
like that, because you get
cute little maths apps.
And then I kind of looked at the
phonics stuff and the reading
stuff, and it was just
always multi-choice.
Anything to do with reading and
language learning was always
multi-choice, because
I kind of figure out--
I went they have no way
of assessing whether she
could get this right or not.
So she was playing
these beautiful games.
They're all done-- the
pedagogy was great,
in the [INAUDIBLE] app, but
they had no way of assessing.
And I remember asking her--
she'd completed a level
or whatever it was,
and I was asking, you
just finished that?
And then, you know, I'd
ask her what the sound was,
what the word was, and
she'd go, I don't know.
And then I started watching
what she was doing.
She was just gaming
them, because she'd
got around the first time.
She just knew the next time
how to do the other one.
And she had no clue
what they were--
you know, she didn't
know what the sound was;
she had no ability to recall,
and she wasn't able to read
the sound or the word.
And to my mind that
meant there was--
why has nobody done anything
on this, because you know,
I'd been working on
speech recognition
for so long at that
point, and I knew
where we were going with
adult speech recognition.
The writing was on
the wall that we'd be
at this voice assistance stage.
So it was just baffling to
me that nobody had actually
put any-- not that they hadn't
put effort into it; they have.
They just hadn't got
to the same stage.
And that's why I spent
quite a bit of time trying
to figure out what
the problem was,
and why nobody had done that.
So it was definitely
my experience
coupled with sitting with
my daughter and going,
ah, right, there--
and then realizing
it was actually bigger than
I thought, the problem.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
And then the last five
years-- so I mean,
you spent a lot of time working
with some of the biggest names.
Certainly IBM, Bell
Labs-- you're now
in a startup environment.
What have you taken
from that time
in the corporate environment?
So many of us here are
working in big companies.
We'd like to think we're a
startup in many ways in Google.
But what have you
taken, and what are you
applying in your
current role today
that you've learned in
your corporate time.
PATRICIA SCANLAN: So we're B2B.
So we don't bring products
to market ourselves.
We license our technology.
So it was one of my learnings,
probably from my Bell Labs days
that, you know, it's
such a big ecosystem.
To possibly say I was going
to do everything myself.
Every bit of funding
I would have raised
would have gone way too thin.
And I realized that in order
to develop the technology
we needed-- and I
actually realized slowly
over time how big
a problem it was,
and how difficult a problem it
was, that the minute we started
going to the end user, and
we started going to B2C,
we have to invest a huge amount
of technology in that end of it
as well-- sorry funding,
actually, and resources.
So when we were in Bell
Labs, one of the thinking
was, and part of
the corporate thing
is, you don't have
to do everything.
You know, you can
partner, and you
can actually just decide and
laser focus on this problem,
and then find partners, because
that's what big companies do;
they partner--
where it makes sense.
But what I learned also was
how to talk to corporates,
and to know what
their problems were,
and their pain points, and
realize actually sometimes
the left hand doesn't know
what the right hand is doing.
So you know, what we've
discovered-- sometimes
we go to a big organization, get
a contact, and talk to someone.
They might not think
they have a problem,
realize they have a problem, or
that person is just too busy.
Or they haven't put
it as a priority.
You might actually talk
to a different person
at the organization, and
this is their pain point,
and they will talk to you,
and you start engaging.
So I think sometimes people,
you talk to them in corporate,
you get one thanks, we're all
right, and you think that's it,
and you walk away.
But you know, realizing
that very big corporations,
it's just not
possible to know what
every part of the
organization is doing.
It's served us well.
And then realizing where
in the organization
to try and get contacts into.
It's definitely
relationship building
over the last couple of years.
And we kind of use a lot of
our professional contacts
in the last 20 years,
and to help getting
to talk to the right people.
That's important to do.
SPEAKER 1: Any big surprises?
I mean, in 2013 to
today I'm sure there's
been lots of ups and
downs in the journey.
But what's kind of
surprised you most
that you weren't thinking before
you took the leap into starting
a company?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: I was
full sure at the start
that I'd have more
competitors right now.
But I then, in my two, three
years, four years into it,
oh, that's why, this
is really bloody hard.
[LAUGHS] Well, those
people will go fry
bigger fish like
before they'll do this.
But we've been very
focused on [INAUDIBLE]..
But yeah, I think
two things happened.
I'm surprised it took as long as
it did for the voice assistance
to take off.
But that's fair enough.
There's always many
factors for that.
And then in the child's
speech, I definitely
think people are
waking up to the fact
that it's a problem today.
Again, thought that would
have happened earlier.
But that's fine.
We're in a great
position at the moment.
SPEAKER 1: Good problems, there.
Good surprises to find there.
PATRICIA SCANLAN: It's
not a bad problem.
SPEAKER 1: In terms of
yourself, your own time--
and one of the things that
we talk a lot about at Google
is work/life balance, trying to
figure out how you prioritize.
I mean, you've got
a lot on your plate.
You've got the tech side.
You've got the vision.
You've got the business.
How do you determine
your priorities
on a given week,
or a given month,
in terms of what
you specifically
are doing versus
your team, given
the opportunity from what
you've described earlier on
is just so big?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: I wish I
had said I know how I do that.
I don't.
We prioritize on the fly.
I mean, my job is CEO,
and it changes by the day.
I mean, honestly, I'd
be bucking the painter,
because we just moved
into a new office
where I'll be talking to legal,
or talking to accountancy,
or flying into San
Francisco, or to New York.
And every week is
completely different.
And you're just
constantly just weighing
up stuff in your
head dynamically.
What you told us was
a priority last week
suddenly drops, because
something else just happened.
But just having a good
team, and everybody.
I think what helps
priorities is always
having the vision in mind.
And one thing
we've never changed
is that the voice
technology, getting
the best possible
platform, that serves
into our different verticals.
That is a system that
everybody can use,
and we don't have to
custom for everybody.
All those things have
been a focal point for us.
So if we have a number
of different clients,
and they're all looking
for different things,
we actually say no a lot.
That helps, not being
afraid to say no.
Because just because you
want it, if nobody else,
no other client wants it, that's
probably not a priority for us.
So we try and build
something that's
a useful product to as
many people as possible.
And things like
that, always having
that in mind when you're
making your priority
list for the week.
SPEAKER 1: Pivoting
back into the business,
you presented a
whole lot of logos
at the very, very start,
some of the biggest companies
in the world all in this space.
And commercialization
of voice technology.
Where do you see,
five, 10 years going?
What's your perspective on
the revenue streams that
are going to come out of
these technologies for all
these companies?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: I think
a lot of the conversation
now is about winning the home.
I think that's what's a
driver for most people.
I mean, they're not
charging for it.
But what people
are trying to do,
I think is to draw
you into an ecosystem,
and have that ecosystem be
as useful as possible to you.
It's not about the
voice technology per se.
It's about you using
one device over another,
paying for the
hardware, or maybe you
do you're buying there, or
maybe your services that you
enlist, who's giving
you the best experience.
And that's where you go.
And what most of these bigger
companies have realized
is that I'm on an Apple fan.
I've got an iPhone.
I've got a MacBook.
And I will probably get the
HomePod if they ever fix Siri.
Those type of things.
It's kind of like being
a McDonald's lifer.
That's why I kind of see where
people are viewing the utility
and revenue streams.
But that's not to say it's
not going to change, either.
I think it's going to be a case
if your product will look less
for not having good voice
technology as an interface,
you'll look like
antiquated technology.
And there's cars
that are partnering
with some pretty big speech
technology companies to bring
[INAUDIBLE].
The Tesla's got pretty good
speech recognition technology
going.
You can't bring out a quality
product now without it.
So over time it's going to
just become more of the norm.
And everything you sell
them, the majority of it
will be done by voice.
SPEAKER 1: And has that
evolution changed your thinking
on how SoapBox are approaching
the market over the last five
years?
Things have moved very,
very fast in the market.
Have you had to pivot?
Have you had to twist,
have you had to change,
or is your approach
still the same?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: We started
using the word "skills"
in the last year.
I think that's changed.
But it's literally an app
on a voice device like so.
But in some ways
we always designed
it to be an underlying
technology that would
serve into education, gaming.
We always had the
utility box there,
which is I think that
whole advice when
you talk about voice control,
robotics, the AR VR, all that.
Toys is a big one as well.
What changed a lot for us is
over the years that we started
putting a stronger and stronger
focus on data privacy and data
protection, and what that means.
And we want to be sure that
we were leading the field,
and that we know how it works.
And we want to make
sure that we can
help other people be compliant.
To my mind, it was knowing
that was going to be a problem.
And you better hit those
things head-on earlier.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
And maybe going a bit more
specific on the offering.
So sitting underneath
SoapBox Labs,
there's obviously some IP
in terms of development.
How have you gotten there
in terms of really getting
something unique and
something different
that's not available
in the marketplace,
so the ideas, the
[INAUDIBLE] the technologies.
What exactly is under the hood?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: As I kind
of pointed a little bit
in the talk was about the data.
We use state-of-the-art
deep-learning technologies.
We've over eight
years' experience
in the team in speech
recognition technology.
That's actually growing.
We might have to add to that.
We concentrated on
quality data first.
I recognized that problem after
my experience in Bell Labs.
Actually, it was Google
back in the early 2000s that
started a really
clever data collection
program, these GOOG-411 that
you'd ring and ask for advice.
You'd get free information call
if you used voice technology
back in the early 2000s.
And it was actually
a very effective way
of collecting data.
GOOG started a long
time before anyone else.
But my own experience, I worked
a number of different projects
in the Bell Labs days, where
lab-like data versus real-world
data--
actually, in IBM as well--
was that you can collect
all the data in the world,
and build a very
efficient system.
But if it's not
representative of where
you expect to use the voice
technology, it won't work.
And all those
learnings have lead
us to do things in
a different order
than other people were doing it.
We were concentrating
on quality data,
understanding the problem,
understanding the application
areas.
And then [INAUDIBLE]
state-of-the-art technology,
and our cloud-based API,
and making it available,
and all those things.
So there's kind
of multiple areas
of expertise from the team and
our own experience as well.
People who came [INAUDIBLE],,
how we do it, how we address
behaviors.
All that, as well as
the thousands of hours
of data that we acquired.
SPEAKER 1: Good to hear.
A lot in there.
Maybe open it to the floor.
Any questions for Patrica?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the talk.
Very interesting.
I was wondering if you
could share some information
about the effect that it has
on children, too, especially
on their behavior, right?
So with the products that
are on the market now,
it's very often that
all that is needed
is a command or an
order, basically.
So you say, hey Google, do this.
But you never say,
please, or thank
you, or anything like that.
So what kind of
impact does that have
on the behavior of a child that
they think that that's normal?
And when they ask someone
else do something else,
to someone else, are they going
to copy that behavior as well?
Or do they realize that they're
not talking to technology?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: It depends on
the age of the child, I guess.
As a parent, I would
always advocate
you say "please" regardless.
So it comes from the parent.
I mean, as much as the child
could be rude to another human,
I think you teach those
behaviors in some ways.
The fact that Alexa will do,
or Google Home will do it
regardless, maybe that's a
little add-on, or a little
opt-in that you got to do.
She won't do it unless
you say, please.
I'll push that back in
Google to address that issue.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about the product.
Is it more like a classifier
for a kid's voice,
or is it speech
cognition including kids?
PATRICIA SCANLAN:
A classifier--?
AUDIENCE: --for kids.
For a kid's voice.
For instance is you're
trying to predict
if this is a kid speaking,
or children speaking.
Or is it more speech recognition
including kids, trying
to understand what they say?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: We do both.
So we recognize adult versus
child as a classification.
And then there's also a
speech recognizer as well.
AUDIENCE: And for
the classifier,
how do you classify?
What is the threshold for being
a voice as a children voice,
or adult voice?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: So
traditionally it's
kind of a well-recognized
problem that
under the age of 12 is when
you find the voice starting
to differentiate the most.
So that depends on
the client, let's say,
coming to us about what
their specification is,
what would they rather happen.
It's not going to be binary.
It's not going to
be black and white.
So you're not going to be able
to say, I have a cut-off at 13,
because you're going to
have some 11 year olds that
are going to speak like a 13
year old and a 13 year old's
going to speak like
an 11 year old.
So you will have that
little gray area there.
But it's quite clear once you
start going anywhere younger.
AUDIENCE: And can
I ask the accuracy?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: Of--?
AUDIENCE: --of the
classification.
Are you saying this is kid's
voice, or not kid's voice,
and for the age, for instance?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: I can
share more information but it
would very much depend on--
I think, like you
say, if you're going
to say, can I recognize a four
or five year old from an adult,
I'd say 100% accuracy.
If you're going to
start saying, can I
recognize a 12 year old from
an adult, that gets harder.
It's very easy to separate
young children from adults.
I'll say that for [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEXA: You mentioned you
have an Alexa at home.
Do you have any other
voice assistance at home?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: No, I don't.
We have a Bixby and a
Siri on our home devices.
AUDIENCE: And is it purely
out of professional interest
that you have it at
home, or do you actually
use it for queries?
PATRICIA SCANLAN:
Yeah, it was definitely
bought as a research
piece of equipment.
I think I bought it from the
US, because I wanted to have it
back in 2015 or 2016.
And then I have access
to a Google Homes.
We've been testing that as well.
We use it.
We definitely use it as
usually timers, alarms.
Playing music is a
big one in our house.
How do you spell this.
General knowledge, just
for fun, sometimes.
I think the utility
can be better.
I think we haven't
quite seen it yet.
I think it's quite limited.
And sometimes on an Amazon,
like if you actually
see it working in somewhere
like the US, or London,
where you've got Uber, and
you've got your deliveries.
The way you've got
"Call me an Uber."
That's what I want
to be able to do.
We can't do that
here in Ireland.
So I think in Ireland
we're somewhat limited,
because they only just
released it for Ireland.
And it depends on what
it's connected to,
and what apps you enable.
I think we're
somewhat limited here.
I've definitely seen
better utility in the US.
ALEXA: And from your
personal experience,
which one do you
find more accurate,
the Alexa or the Google Home?
[LAUGHTER]
PATRICIA SCANLAN: I would say
Google in the natural language
understanding for sure.
You get way too many "I don't
know what that means" on Alexa.
But I think that's an
understood problem.
And then there's
problems vice versa.
I think both of them
have their strengths.
It depends on what
you're linked into.
Depends on what
you need as well.
I think actually,
people, you never
really hear one's going to be
that strong over the other.
I think when it comes to
kid's speech, I won't say.
We've done our own empirical
research on that one.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You talk about
speech recognition, of course,
but is there a lot of focus
also on the other side?
So I mean for me,
it's really weird
that we have this advanced
speech recognition everywhere.
But the system that
asks-- especially
in this [? AVR ?] system is
very clunky still, very robotic.
And very if you want
blah, blah, [INAUDIBLE]..
So is there anything going
on, especially for kids,
on how this is served?
This is a fun assistant, and he
doesn't ask and answer in a way
that you might expect.
So a bit more
human-like, or maybe
throwing a joke in,
or presenting it
in a different way, or
is this completely--
are these two
separate fields or is
this the same kind of companies
that work [INAUDIBLE]??
PATRICIA SCANLAN: Kind of like
chat bot type thing with voice.
Is that what you mean?
AUDIENCE: So the
assistant being more
of a person than just
a piece of technical.
I can relate to that person.
He has some silly
jokes, and I program him
for the personality,
that kind of thing.
PATRICIA SCANLAN: There's
nothing really on the market
that's blown us away.
But we know there's a huge
amount of companies looking
at this, and not a huge
amount of research done on it,
actually, funny enough.
We've looked, and we've
been asked about it recently
about that exactly, that
what would that voice
assistant, or chat bot for
child, what makes more sense.
Because kids use
different language.
Their concepts are simpler.
You can't use a lot of what
you would use for an adult
with a child, because
they won't get it.
And it's not
appropriate sometimes.
Even the concept can be
just too much for them.
They don't get subtleties.
And then again, it
depends on the age group.
You're talking about 4 to 7, or
are you talking about 9 to 12?
Very little actually.
Very little has been done.
But then again, you think
about the whole chat bot,
that kind of
automated assistant,
that natural
language, understand,
it's still quite new for adults.
We're only getting
better at it now.
And what I've seen
is quite a lag
on what will happen for kids.
It will happen.
We've seen a lot of
people working on it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks a lot
for the presentation.
Because of the nature
of your company,
I guess you have collective
access to a lot of data,
and voice samples
of little kids.
So if you could share how do you
approach gathering this data,
collecting this, or buying
this, getting access to it.
And how do you make sure
it is compliant with all
of the privacy regulations
that you just mentioned?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: So we
just do it ourselves.
We don't talk too much
about how we do it.
But from the get-go
in 2013, we've
been fully compliant
with COPPA because I
started the company myself.
So I made sure I was engaged
with privacy lawyers,
and understanding this.
And more so understanding
that we didn't really
have an obligation to
do it in the beginning.
But it was one of
those things I really
thought was going
to be an issue,
and it should be an issue,
and it should be addressed.
So for a small
company, I don't think
it's worth taking risks
on something like that.
So we've done
everything ourselves.
And I'm glad about that as
well, because it actually
wasn't even possible
to buy data,
because there isn't anything
equivalent out there.
Not in real world data, not in
[INAUDIBLE] on a mobile device,
not in a real environment,
not in uncontrolled ways.
And to my mind, everything
else was useless.
Because again, like I said,
if the only data you could buy
was fairly lab-like environment,
and controlled by an adult
or a parent sitting there
making a child read something,
that's not real-world stuff.
So we've been very careful
to do it ourselves.
We've been careful to
be compliant globally.
And to that end, that's
another value to us.
It's means we can stand
over what we've done.
AUDIENCE: Right.
That's a a lot of
effort, I guess,
to gather this type of data.
PATRICIA SCANLAN: Yeah.
It was a huge [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So one
follow-up question, then.
Do you then take
into consideration
to make sure you
collect the samples
from different countries,
different cultures,
just to avoid the
cultural country bias?
PATRICIA SCANLAN: Yeah.
We have data from over
170 countries now,
and tens of thousands, or we're
actually more than that now.
That was huge, as well,
actually to be honest.
Because I lived in the
US for quite a bit,
in different areas.
And one of the
things I always noted
was if you live in
New York, or if you
drop a pin on a
school in New York,
I'm sure you're not going
to get more than 20%
of New York accent.
So why just build a
system with US accents?
And that was really
key, that if a system's
going to work
everywhere, the world
doesn't work like that anymore.
You've got such flow
of people, whatever.
And to be honest, deep learning
and all those technologies,
the advent of that
has allowed us
to be able to add multiple
variations in pronunciation
to the system, whereas when
I started this back in 2000,
you'd probably have a
model from mid-Western US,
and [INAUDIBLE].
And even at that,
you probably have
to break it into different
dialects and accents and stuff
like that, because
the systems couldn't
cope with the variation, where
we can now, which is amazing.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thank you for the talk.
Really interesting.
I actually got interested in
the topic because of "AdWeek"
and a talk about that as
well, on the future of search.
So it had a lot of
similar implications
in terms of what happens
if a child is in the room,
and also what does that mean
for advertising in voice search.
Do you have any take on the
combination of advertising
in voice search in the future,
and children being in the room?
Because there's a lot of
regulations and problems
with that, too.
PATRICIA SCANLAN:
Yeah, I think it'd
be much like I said about
the appropriateness,
that for advertisers,
I think you don't want
to waste time
advertising to children,
because they're not the buyers.
So I mean as much
as you ethically
need to be able to make it
an appropriate experience
for a child, you
also commercially
shouldn't be wasting
advertising dollars
on advertising to a child.
So I think again the simple
adult/child classifiers
for different age groups
as well is appropriate.
Even on apps now
these days, there's
quite strict regulations--
not regulations,
more like guidelines as
well-- about what you
should advertise to children.
So while some apps are free,
you can slot in static ads.
But it should be an
ad on Lego or Barbie.
But it shouldn't be an ad
on something inappropriate.
And I think that's just
business sense, really, as well.
I mean, there's one
side that regulation's
going to force us all to
do these things correctly.
It's about time.
But on the other side, there's
definitely just good sense
about as much as you target your
ads to different demographics
I think.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
One more question?
I'll take the last one.
Usually people start
running at 5:00
to get to their next
meetings, and I'm
guessing a lot of people
here will be doing that.
We've talked a lot about
the hard work to date,
the problems you're solving,
the things you're going after.
Let's look out in
10 years, your hope
for SoapBox Labs, where you'll
be, what you'll be doing.
Would you like to share
any of the future--
PATRICIA SCANLAN:
Yeah, I mean initially
for the next few
years, anyway, we've
got a big focus on multilingual.
I think that's a huge thing.
We can't just
continue to expect--
It's been such a hard slog to
get anything quality out there
in English.
But we've learned so much.
We've got our pipelines.
We've got our processes.
We can accelerate
now adding languages.
And that's what we raised
EU funding for, actually.
We raised quite considerable
funding at the end of last year
to take our platform
multi-lingual.
So that's going to be a
massive focus of the company.
And eventually there's lots
of different variations
of speech, all types of
voice technology, where
voice comes into it.
And it's kids.
That's where we'll be.
And we're already
building up our expertise
in a number of different
areas, do more natural language
understanding as well around
children, things like that.
And we listen a lot to what
our clients are saying to us,
and what they want to be
able to bring to market.
So as much as we'll do certain
amounts of it at the moment,
but we're listening all
the time to what they want,
and but without going
into too much detail,
we're responding to that.
And right now we have a
great position in the market,
because we have quite a
lead, because we focus solely
on that we haven't diversified
over the last five years
on kids.
But there's so
many opportunities.
Globally there's so
many opportunities
in this [INAUDIBLE].
So yeah, we'll just
keep those [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER 1: Well, great
space, great company.
And thank you very much
for taking the time,
coming in to talk to us
here, sharing your journey,
sharing the SoapBox Lab journey.
Best wishes for the future.
I mean, I know pretty
much everyone in this room
is probably excited about
where voice is going,
where the technology is going.
And it's great to see an Irish
company, an indigenous company,
doing real tech work
here with an ambition
to go global as well.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]